four years ago um
i i was finding things very very
difficult and i've been medicated for 28
years
properly medicated not just through a
friend right right
and four years ago uh i tried to take my
life
and it wasn't for attention i just
couldn't oh mrs
couldn't bear it couldn't bear it right
you died yes
yes and i remember that time and i
remember
i remember us wanting to give you your
space and your privacy
so i went to uh a place to to give me
help
and the one thing that shocked me
into like come on missus you've got to
get this together
where there were two girls there with me
and
they were in there because they were
drinking and using drugs
and they told me they were drinking and
using drugs they
weren't even related young girls and
both of them their mother had committed
suicide
and it messed them up so bad
that they couldn't cope with their life
right and that
shocked me into carmon
am i going to do this to my family to my
babies
no way and that shocked me it was like
an electric shock and it was like get it
together
[Music]
you